we do have a new poll in which Joe Biden
is leading Donald Trump by four points
this is a hypothetical 2024 general
election poll this is a poll that
assumes trumps the Republican nominee
Biden is the Democratic nominee and the
election were held today
in this poll Quinnipiac Biden leads
Trump 48 to 44. Trump's support has
dropped two points since uh Trump was
um since the last time this poll was
done in late may I like to get a more
General look at polling if we look at
the best rated polls b-plus and higher
we have a recent you gov poll that poll
says Biden and Trump are actually tied
among registered voters with Trump
leading by one among all adults we then
have the a minus rated Quinnipiac poll
the one I just described to you it has
Biden ahead of Trump by four and then we
have an A minus Suffolk University poll
which has Biden leading DeSantis by
seven and Biden leading Trump by two
what we can say at this point is that
there is a really big red flag and the
red flag isn't oh Biden's winning or
Biden's losing or whatever the red flag
is Biden has done a number of good
things as far as presidents are
concerned we have a stable economy at
worst if not a solid economy
Trump has been arrested multiple times
lies constantly
fundraises on grifts is facing all sorts
of different problems after losing for
the Republican party in 2018 2020 and
and pushing them to lose uh or not win
by as much as they should have in 2022
and given all of that Biden's only
winning by one two three or four
that's the red flag this if this country
made sense
if voters reacted sensibly and soberly
and thoughtfully to the facts of the
world
Joe Biden would be leading at minimum by
double digits and so to anybody who's
looking at this current election and
saying oh this is they're just these
Republicans aren't going to win there's
no way Trump can win there's no way this
country would re-elect Trump
the polling even if you believe right
like the best one of these polls the
strongest one of these polls is Biden
leading Trump by four even if you
believe that
it is an absolute and total horror show
and we should all be very much aware
that Trump could win
and we need to activate any tool we have
to prevent that from happening and of
course by the way I mean an illegal tool
including voter turnout campaigning
debate prep surrogates what all of the
legal things all of the legal things as
always as if I even really have to
clarify that scary stuff
on tape showing National secrets to
guests at his Resort
and uh the best poll we can find has him
down four just absolutely horrifying
stuff
30 million trees are destroyed every
year for toilet paper in the U.S alone
so toilet paper is a big contributor to
deforestation and climate change our
sponsor real paper makes toilet paper
from bamboo bamboo plants keep growing
which means no deforestation bamboo also
absorbs five times as much carbon from
the atmosphere as pine trees and bamboo
toilet paper is stronger than regular
toilet paper and even softer so bamboo
toilet paper is all around a win for you
and for the environment it's time to
move on from that toilet paper from
trees that you're using at home when you
use real paper it doesn't feel like
you're sacrificing anything it's soft
and fluffy and they'll ship it to your
door in plastic free packaging on a
schedule super easy with every box of
real paper you buy they are funding
reforestate efforts across the country
through their partnership with one tree
planted so unlike the toilet paper that
cuts down trees real is helping to
actively plant them go to realpaper.com
Pacman and use code Pacman for 30 off
your first order and free shipping the
link is down below